return to team up with JTOK for for one
last job. For one last job here, mutual
enemy. Enemy and my enemy.
Dan does kind of have the money to make
this person's life Helen. They're making
it quite easy right now.
>> A Stoke server.
>> I don't really understand the strategy
here, but Dan has just uh messaged me
saying, "I didn't care at first, but now
that food shops is calling me a child. I
think I'm seriously at risk." So, big
Dan versus Food Shops drama. So, we've
got we got all the clips here, I think.
So, this all starts about 5 days ago
when Mr. Mutton calls food shops a
pedophile.
Daniel. All right. Danny Boy and Mr.
Moton. Okay. See, this is what I mean by
people going after me. Okay. Like this
is what I mean by people going after me
for no reason. All right, for Dan, I
think Dan is the only exception where
Dan has not gone after me personally,
but I am going after Dan just simply
because
I feel like I have a justified reason to
do so. Okay, that's fair. Okay, Dan has
every reason to be mad at me for going
after me. I'm not going to complain
about that. Okay, because I hate Dan.
Now, with that being said, with that
being said, okay,
>> what the [__] did I do to Mr. Mutin? I'm
sorry. Does Mr. Mutin and Dan share a
single brain cell
>> like [clears throat] you guys are like
squabbbling over like how the fates
squabble over like the single eyeball?
Here, let me just play this.
>> Z is probably going to win and that's
okay.
>> This is g me a headache.
>> No [__] no. That would be ally of the
year or something. That is not um
>> buddy. [laughter] So, uh,
>> I've heard that
>> CJ, tell me about it, man.
What am I paying for at this point? What
am I paying for at this point?
>> A pedophile.
>> I'm not going to say anything.
>> What the [__]
Hello.
I Dude, it's crazy.
>> Was that a pedophile?
I've heard that food shops is
unironically a pedophile.
I'm not going to say any
>> what the
que shops content. Are you going to
dominate her statistically like a real
man?
>> That's disgusting. Thank you for the
crona though. 50 croner. Thank you.
>> Oh,
hello.
I Dude, it's crazy. It's crazy up in
this [__] I just get jacketed by like
[__] Mr. Martin. What the [__]
>> thing here? Um, but I before I had no
issue I'm not I'm not going to say
anything here.
>> Yeah, of course. Like it's crazy to me
how Dan is more submissive than Mr.
Mutin. Okay. [laughter]
>> It's not really pedojacking, is it?
Mr. Mutin is like dumb enough to say
something like that. Oh my god. It's
like Beas and Buttthead, dude. Wait,
hold on. I actually want to see this
whole thing is a little bit, right?
>> It's fine.
>> Z is probably going to win. And that's
okay.
>> I just I'm just curious about the
>> contest. The ally.
>> She described herself as a pedophile.
Small P, but did say she would describe
herself as a small P pedophile.
like not a clinical pedophile, someone
with like a subclinical attraction to
children
of some form.
That's I believe
the the rough message of that
>> of the year or something something that
is not um
>> buddy. [laughter] So uh
>> I've heard that food shops is
unironically a pedophile.
the
>> food chops is full trans.
>> That's crazy, bro. Anyway, it it doesn't
really matter. Like, dude, bro, [__]
Steven's orbit, dude. And I'm going
every single time Steven comes in here
or I talk to Steven, I'm just going to
say it again and again. It doesn't
really matter if he never joins in here
again or never talks to me again.
>> I did I did watch the eviction stuff.
Is she living with like fans or
something? I I think right she she lives
with people who watch her streams and
they're kicking her out because they
expected to have friend a friend
roommate, not just a roommate who sits
in their room screaming all day
basically.
Dude, [__] DG, dude. DG is ass, bro. DG
is ass. I It's so crazy. Like it's so
crazy to me how um DG
like Destiny
is admirable because he's able to have
Okay, I I think that's all I want to
hear from that to be honest. So then
we've got three days ago Dan called food
chops a pedophile.
>> Thank you.
>> All right, that was all.
>> Bye-bye.
Nice.
>> I don't want to say food shops is wrong
about what?
>> Well, they're a pedophile, so that's
kind of expected.
>> Dang.
>> Why is it Why has Darius been in here?
>> And that's why not happy. That is not a
happy look, is it?
>> Criticize his parenting. Okay,
>> that's why I think it's a reasonable
escalation. Okay, that's why I think
it's a reasonable escalation. Okay. I
hope that your wife gets harassed more
at work. Okay.
>> This whole time,
>> huh?
>> Oh, is Dar still in here?
>> He's Yeah, he's been in here.
>> He's the [__] Chad.
>> Good for him. My boy
>> probably got arrested again.
>> Okay.
probably in some drama again.
>> I hear that's been happening.
>> Yeah,
>> that's what I heard.
>> This is a direct result of Desi getting
down with Oxy. That's absolutely true.
Desis encourage this behavior. Um
yeah,
there's just no there is no
justification for this here. You know,
you [snorts] called yourself a
pedophile. Dan is just saying the same
thing. You can't call yourself a
pedophile, like take it back and start,
you know, like threatening or
encouraging [__] against people who just
say that.
>> Just remember, every single battle I
pick is justified. Okay. Just want to
>> Okay,
>> just in case anyone wonders if I'm being
unhinged.
>> Well, if you say it's justified, then it
must be.
>> All right. Well,
I love you guys and uh stay safe. Be
careful.
All right. See you, man.
>> Jesus.
>> Well, what can you do? Haters going to
hate. Okay.
They hate us cuz they ain't us. True.
Holy [__] Fas,
>> bro. He called me a pedto. Yeah. Of
course I won't feel bad for him anymore.
Yeah. Or for his wife or for his kids.
What the [__] Of course not. I hope
they get harassed more.
>> There's actually no evidence to relax or
anything. I don't know why. I hope he
gets spotted. I don't care.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right, cool. Um,
>> yeah, like just it's just going after
people's family at the best of times is
like [__] pretty low. This is like so
just unjustified. It's just bizarre.
It's just like like you just look
[__] terrible.
I think that afterwards
um I think that afterwards um he hop
into Zip Zip stream. Why does he call
you a pedo? Good question.
But it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter
whether or not he calls me a pedo,
right? It like to me it doesn't matter.
It could be either from the anti-fan
videos. It could be either from rumors.
It could be either from Mr. Mutin or
he's just saying that because he likes
calling everyone a pito. It does it
doesn't matter. No, I don't
>> like like once you go there, I'm just
I'm just going to do tiff for tat. Like
at that point, I'm just going to do tiff
for tat, right?
>> Um yeah, there there's no reason for me
to like hold back anymore at that point.
Yeah, points does that as well. Yeah.
And I and I also criticize him and his
family. I do that too because he went
there. Yeah, of course.
>> Or of course I'm not going to cater my
dialogue to further [laughter] feelings
at some point. Okay. Of course not. What
the [__] This is just so bizarre.
>> And and by the way, even then even then
I still like I still compliment
counterpoints despite that. It's like so
crazy to me.
>> Thank you.
>> All right. That was all.
>> Okay. Well, that's that clip. There's
some image links here, but I can't open
those in the UK. So, but my
understanding is that um
basically Dan and Food Shop's talking
DMs. Food Chops is trying to cut a deal
with Dan to not get called a pedophile
anymore. And uh that's Dan's not playing
ball at all. Dan is not interested. So
it it doesn't it doesn't go well. It
doesn't go well to say the least. This
results in food shops getting banned
from the Taliban Twitter community.
Here's the images.
tried to deescalate one step with Dan
and since he declined, I have no reason
not to post it on Twitter anymore in
public or in the community group.
Putting it here in public also helps
archiving since he loves redacting
things. Hey yo, listen.
I'm not okay with you calling me a
pedophile on stream. We're going to have
our massive disagreements and we're
going to beef. That's fine. However,
using Steven's platform to call me a
pedo is another step up from trolling
you. I'm not okay with it. I'm sending
this because a friend said I should try
direct communication and I agree. I
think it's better to resolve this in
DMs. Even if you do it as a joke, it
obviously still perpetuates or
propagates it. If you agree to stop
calling me a PDF, then I will stop
calling you a child molester in
response. And I won't engage in tit for
tat
and just uh criticize your ego and your
actions which has step down from PDF
jacking [__] Do we have a truce? This
isn't even really tit for tat. Like why
don't you call him a pedophile in
response? You know, you can you can try
and do a bad faith like if you think
Dan's being bad faith with you calling
you a pedophile, why don't you try and
do a bad faith pedophile accusation
back? There's plenty you can work with.
You know,
that would be the tip for tat. This is
like just spazzing out. [cough]
Yeah. Make Hawaii jokes. Make tiny chat
jokes.
He [__] hates that.
Never mention my name again and I won't
talk about you again. You're on random
rants about me and fafo. So [__] around
and find out. Dan, I criticize you for
your ego and you think calling me a pedo
is okay. Then fine, no truce. I think I
made the step to make peace and people
can't say I haven't tried. Now, this is
not a reasonable compromise to me
considering how my entire streaming [__]
is talking about Destiny related figures
and drama. My honest You're coming after
my career, right? Cuz it was on
Destiny's platform. My honest opinion on
them. I'm sorry. It is what it is. And I
guess a truce isn't possible. Have a
good day. Because Destiny's community
really care if someone gets labeled as a
pedophile, don't they? That will stop
them watching them. Dan, I criticize you
for your ego. Oh, wait. No, that's the
same message. Thumbs up. They deleted
his messages instantly. Log them before
he could. Thankfully, that's it. Dan is
rich and has no scruples. This is the
worst possible enemy. Yeah, it's been
said. It's been said.
So, removed from the community for not
respecting Destiny and stream guests.
And then there's just like some DMs
Destiny didn't respond to where food
shops is ranting in DMs. I don't really
care about those. Apparently, food shops
went live and started bitching about it
and then Dan went into JSTO's server.
I'm just going to assume
>> basically basically Dan returned to team
up with JTO for for one last job. For
one last job here, mutual enemy enemy of
my enemy.
He's going to cover that. Maybe he'll
get to it. Maybe he won't get to it.
Okay, who the [__] knows? All right, it
doesn't really matter. All right. All
you need to know is that it seems as
though from what I see, maybe he'll
cover it, maybe he won't, is that he'll
cover me versus Dan Salman. Okay, fine.
This is no accident.
So, you know how Dan is supposed to be a
defender of Destiny against all the
anti-fans? So, I'm being told and I have
received screenshots of Dan on JSTK
server.
>> Oh, no.
>> Trying to incite [__] against me. And
even though he never talks there, he
went on to Jstalk server anti-fan
communities in order to complain about
me. Okay,
so we have the friend of destiny.
>> Dan doesn't care about collateral in his
war on Twitch. So I don't care if his
Russian male order bride gets harassed.
Well, I don't think that's the right
mindset. I think you should uphold the
standard even for people who don't. And
also, even if you don't care about his
wife, I feel like you should scare his
kids.
I feel like that's the normal normal
response.
>> Patronizing with the enemy. Okay. So,
that's what's happening. Okay. Do you
think Dan is on the other side? I think
that somehow because he's so spiteful
that he has decided it would be a great
idea to um complain about me on JK
server. Okay. Yes. It's as crazy as it
sounds. Okay. So, this person named
Hassan, but make no mistake, this is
Dan. I I believe that multiple people
have told me that this is Dan. Yes, it
is Dan. The person with the so-called
Hassan about Fair enough.
So, um
>> I just I just think that if you're the
moment someone's like, you know,
harassing family, it's hard to start
distinguishing
>> redact or reduct.dev. Okay. Obviously,
the real Hassan would never
>> you're going after family. You're going
after family. You're probably you're
probably going to end up, you know, kind
of harming the kids by knock on anyway.
>> [__] server tag. That would be crazy
if so, right? Um so, I'm being told that
this is the real Dan. Okay. Obviously,
you can prove me wrong. Please, please,
please tell me if I'm getting any facts
wrong. Again, I am trying to I'm trying
my hardest, okay, to get all the facts
correct and in order, okay, from
beginning to end. Okay. All right.
So,
Dan, not Hassan says, "Oh, no." So, he
posts this, shares this in Jtok server
of all things. JSTK server
like my public call out. Okay, fine.
Okay, you want to do that? You want to
incite some real [__] [__] against
me? Okay, you did that. You You're
feeding my my like my enemies, my direct
enemy. And enemies of Steven, by the
way, these are enemies of Steven most of
all. They're not they're not like
immediately enemies of me. Like
obviously by extension they are direct
enemies of me, but like primarily their
target is Steven, right? Like let's be
honest, like taking down me, like if
they take me down, that's only a step in
truly taking down Stephen, right? Does
that make sense?
>> Like I hope that makes their primary
target is not me. Their primary target
is Stephen. Okay, so we have a long
>> is literally doing the the Jeffrey
Abstein and Jeffrey Epstein right now.
They're trying to get to you. They just
have to go through me, you know,
just like Jeffrey Abstein all over
again.
>> It's going to chase the server to post
this [__] like Okay, dude. So So he
shares it here. Okay, because he's like
feeling f of it. All right, so this is
the next
Oh god, dude. This is like this. So,
like you realize how childish this is,
right? Like you'll realize like why I
feel like a 26 year old parent like
[__]
like like this guy. Just keep in mind
this guy's like in his 40s, okay? Like
this guy is like a parent. He's a parent
with a full family. Like a full-fledged
family and multiple business. Like,
bro, I Okay, listen.
To be very frank, okay, to be extremely
frank.
to be extremely frank. Okay, you need to
grow the [__] up. Okay, seriously. Okay,
how is it that I'm more mature? It's
insane. Okay, it's insane. It's insane
that I have to deal with like actual
mench children. Like, what the [__]
Hello. Like, what is this like high
school [__] Like, what's with this
stupid gossip girl high school anyway?
>> So,
>> so we have Oh, Dan just joined the
battle. So, this is confirmation.
>> This is confirmation from like one of
the anti-fans, right? That Oh, yeah. Dan
just joined the battle. So, if you have
any like doubts, if you have any doubts
about this not being Dan, um, yeah, just
if you have doubts about me, just make
sure I'm just saying, okay, this is this
does actually seem to be Dan. Okay, this
anti-fan just said Dan just joined the
battle. Okay,
>> I thought
I think and I don't know if Zip Zip is
there, but this is like this is Dan
saying zip zip. So, this is again this
is in JSON server it seems like, right?
Zip Zip sounds the exact same as Jst
Steelk and Cadence and I don't give a
[__] if anyone thinks I'm [__] So,
let's be clear here, okay? Yes, this is
an insult towards J Stelk, right?
Because again, he's implying that Jelk
sounds horrible, which is absolutely
correct, right? What is this little pin
emoji that Dan put is this meant to be
like the sex offender pin? Is that what
he's doing? [snorts] This is meant to be
the this is meant to be the the like sex
offender map pin, you know, like the
not mappers in mind person, but you know
the map, right? However,
remember this is a double insult, right?
Because he is insulting Jubilee, right?
Making fun of him and he's insulting Zip
Zip, right? So, he's roasting Zip Zip at
the And by the way, I have a suspicion
that this happened right after the
debate between Zip Zip and Dan about the
Celeste thing, the same [__] topic,
the Celeste [__]
What a hello. Anyway, it's just kind of
funny how Dan just [__] molds. He
molds after every interaction. He molds
after every debate.
Do I go onto anti-fan Discord servers to
complain about my ops in DGG? Do I do
that as a 26y old? Hello? You know, I'm
constantly thinking to myself, how do I
be the most mature? Wow. How do I act
the most chill? Uh-huh. This is not it.
Okay. I'm just saying. Okay. Anyway, so
there you go. There's a Zip Zip mention,
I guess. Like also insulting Zip. So So
[clears throat]
Dan then says, "My perfect online
reputation." Okay, so this is sarcastic,
I'm assuming. Okay, whatever. So this my
person says, who is a dedicated anti?
Okay,
>> click the 10 gifted membership. Sugar
locks.
Thank you. Hugely appreciate yours.
Thank you. Hugely generous. Thank you so
much. In Destiny's handmaiden rule, you
must do battle with food chops and zip
zip. Okay, I just I I think this is gay.
Okay, I I don't give a [__] So this
person get does this a laughing emoji,
right? So, it's people who are going
like, "Okay, wait, hold on. Is Dan
coming around to our side? It's time to
seduce Dan into the anti-fan side."
Like, that's that's how I read it at the
very least. Okay.
>> So, Dan didn't say I would be 10 times
more concerned.
>> Like, like this is like um I don't even
think food shops believes that.
>> I think this is like food shops is just
trying to like win over DG to be on her
side in the fight because I don't I
think it's pretty clear what this is.
like Dan just has an issue with with
food shops and knows Jook's community
might be able to help him out with that.
You know,
they can they can on this one issue.
They can be aligned
cuz food shops has gone after JTO so
much. I feel that's pretty clear. I
don't say anything to do with them being
on the antifan side. No, no one's got
any,
you know, illusions about Dan and
Destiny being friends, right? And their
friendship will far outlast any, you
know, [__] streaming orbit connection
that food drops has with Destiny. If
Wolf Gand came at me, this person has no
influence and is a known. This is again,
all right, again, pedal jacketing me.
Okay, so if you guys do don't know, this
is like the um uh sex offense registry
like pin, the red pin that is on sex
offense registry maps. And basically
this is the red pin. He's doing a red
pin emote because he's basically saying,
>> well Dan's doing it because food chop
swung at him, right? He just like
offhand described food shops as a
pedophile on a stream. She spazzed the
[__] out and said his kids deserve to
get [__] harassed and [__]
And so he's just he's fighting back. So
I don't even fault down here. I don't I
don't think it's even about securing his
position or anything.
I think went [__] insane at him.
person on the sex offenders registry
basically is trying to like again pedal
jacking whatever it doesn't matter okay
so and then and then Dan says like a
weird comment like a
I don't know why whatever man you know
his sense of humor is his sense of humor
right so he compares me and Zida to Wolf
Gand okay I I don't know all that much
about Wolf Gang I have I have no beef or
coral with him he disappeared from the J
lookhere a long time ago anyway at least
wolf Wolf,
>> no. Pedo jacketing is like falsely
implying that someone's a pedophile.
>> Has a hot mom. Um, okay. All right. I I
don't know if your wife is okay with
with you saying that. By the way,
normally when someone says, "Oh, yeah."
Like makes your mom jokes. Normally,
it's because it's like it's so absurd
that there's no way it can be true.
>> See, Hightail got an early access
release date for January. Xander won.
Yeah, Xander. I mean, he kind of won.
Yeah. But I mean I I will I will play
Hightail. I'm not even I'm not going to
lie. I was never as hyped for it as
Xander, but I'll play it. I'll give it a
go. So, I mean, I'm not I'm not like,
you know, Xander's W here isn't really
anyone else's L.
I think most people want to give it a
try. Are hoping it's going to be good in
some way,
but like I would probably wager that
Wolf Gang's mom and Dan's age is
probably around the same. I don't know.
Like obviously don't look too much into
it, but like I don't know. This is
obviously half joking, right? Like this
is obviously half joking, right? But
okay, you know, you do your thinking.
All right. Anyway,
>> we will be stream sniping Zanderhole in
Hightail.
>> Um,
let me see.
Okay, let me see. So, this is um, so
this is J Steel
finding out that Dan is complaining
about me. Okay.
So Dan says you said that feeling when
and didn't do a face, [__] Okay.
>> Is it really worth playing in early
access though? It'll probably be [__] if
someone let's say you you went back in
time
Minecraft first first launch first gets
posted online
and you've got all knowledge. You're
really going to say that back then
you're going to be like, "Wow,
Minecraft's [__] early on. Why would I
play it?
you know, if it can hit the same
if if it can sort of uh Minecraft was
not great early on. Super early builds
of Minecraft [__] ass. Like beta 1.2
is like [__] awesome.
Stuff before that is like, you know,
Minecraft already exists. Yeah, but this
is trying to do well I I do understand
in part why Zander Hall was interested
in it
though he didn't seem to understand the
more interesting parts of it. It's like
it's got a lot of mod tools built in,
right, that are meant to make it so that
servers and like uh mod developers and
[__] can really customize and make
custom games and yeah, he's excited for
the story line. [__] [__]
And just the ability to be able to do
that having having something that's got
super powerful mod tools that like lots
of people be able to pick up and create
a [__] for
quite promising.
So this referring to some other
conversation I'm assuming whatever. So
then uh JT says um
and he has talked about Wolf Gang's hot
mom on other occasions. Really?
Okay. Sus. Okay. Whatever. Okay. JK says
to Dan, "Be careful posting in here.
There's someone online threatening to
dox everyone who does." So, this is
talking about Destiny. Okay. This is
talking about Destiny. All right. So, um
because Destiny says, "Oh yeah, if
you're in JSO's community, I'm going to
go around doxing everybody in J who are
like the main stays, right? Because like
I don't give a [__] anymore. I'm just
going to collect all your doxes and just
punish you all." Right? Collect the
punishment. So again, um those are Jay's
dog also poking poking fun at Stephen,
but also poking fun at Dan. Um and and
yeah, saying like, "Oh yeah, you're one
of us now, right?" Like you're you're in
here with us, so be careful. That's
basically what JTO is saying. This does
not sound pointed towards Dan. In my
opinion, just I don't I don't know. Like
>> I don't I don't see any real animosity
between Dan and these anti-fans. All
right. I I don't know if there is. Okay.
I'm being told that Dan does regularly
go into Jay- Silk's community to go
argue with them. I have to say, okay,
you must be doing a really bad job cuz
they just laugh at you all the time.
Okay, Dan. Okay, Dan. All right, listen.
Okay, if you're jealous of me being like
the one true absolute destiny defender,
okay, it's okay. Okay, you're not cut
out for everything in life. Okay, that's
probably why you failed like 10
different businesses, sold off all of
them probably and your workforce to
bigger companies, and now Redact. Dev is
like your baby. So then you have to like
grab a hold of it as you as much as you
can because your previous 10 companies
are all like aborted fetuses that you
like ate for dinner or some [__] Okay,
fine. All right, you want to do your
thing, that's fine. Okay,
>> but listen, not everybody is cut out for
everything, okay? It is what it is. All
right,
>> so you know, there's all these like red
flags going off, okay? Like
like, okay, I can totally acknowledge
Dan being spiteful and doing crazy [__]
okay? But I
did not imagine that
>> does kind of have the money to make this
person's life hell and they're making it
quite easy right now.
>> A Stoke server.
>> I don't really understand the strategy
here
>> to
to to
validate the anti-fans crusade or some
[__] like what the
I mean I guess he's his own person. I
guess he's his own adult. But do you
know what that means when
adults do things? I think that adults
choosing bad decisions like that should
have consequences. I think that should
have consequences in my opinion.
>> All right.
In my opinion.
>> Wow.
>> Okay. Because if you have the mentality
of a child, okay, like Dan does,
and you're very spy driven, okay, which
I understand.
>> Yeah. very lowle check is at play right
now.
>> If you want me to regard you as an
adult, you must take responsibility for
your actions. Okay? I take adult
consequences for my adult actions. All
right? Now, it's time for you to take
yours. In my opinion, if I had absolute
control, you give off so many red flags
that I would oust you instantly. M
twist his balls, you know, send you like
if I had absolute control, I would kick
you out of DG permanently, okay? I would
say you're allowed to be my friend, but
I'm going to kick you out permanently.
Okay? I'm not going to place that
pressure on Stephen. Okay? But I'm just
saying
>> you are problematic. Okay? You are bad
news and problematic. Um, and I think
that all the [__] um
I think that all the DGers who um were
fighting against Dan, I think all their
concerns are validated. Okay, there's a
reason why Dan was doing a 1v20. Okay,
it isn't because Dan is the gigachad
that's like trying to
>> these are the type of people who when
given power abuse it in ways that are
incredible. Dude, who jobs would put the
Stanford prison experiment to shame?
Okay, this is literally this is someone
with
you know that [__] Joey Barton was
saying about Alco and Jeremy Vine. Yeah,
this is like the pole pot mindset. This
is the
the Fred and Rose West mindset. It's
terrifying. It's quite terrifying.
>> The 1v20 martial arts thing, okay? It's
because Dan is just wrong
and everybody else is trying to point
out how wrong he is, but he just won't
back down. Okay, that's literally it.
Okay,
sometimes when you're getting dogpiled,
you think that you're the right one.
Okay, and sometimes when you're getting
dog pile, sometimes you're the [__]
Okay, in this case, he's always the
[__] when he when he's getting dog
piled. Okay, I'm just saying. Um,
so
is the context
clear?
Is the context clear? Now, here's the
thing. Okay,
I think that this is gay. Okay, I think
this is gay and [__] Okay, you're
looking well. Thank you, Rex. Okay,
>> see, now this is uh this is seeming like
getting cold feet. This seem like you're
getting cold feet a little bit.
This is all of a sudden this is gay and
[__] You don't want to do this
anymore.
>> I for one do not enjoy this. Okay, I'm
only doing this because I view this as a
necessity because I know Dan's
character. Okay.
Um,
and honestly, if I monetize this [__]
you know what? I'm all for it. Do you
know why? Is because I think that if I
have to suffer, I think I should at
least make money suffering. Okay?
Because ain't no way you're going to get
me to suffer for free. Okay? Ain't no
way you're going to get me to suffer for
free. There's no way you're doing that
to me. Okay? So, you know what? Yeah, I
am going to stream this. Okay? Now, with
that being said, with that being said,
again, all right. All I'm asking from
Dan is to not call me any child related
[__] crazy [__] when I'm trying to
defend your friend. Okay? I'm trying to
defend
>> a second paper. Quit hating.
>> Yes, I criticize you. Yes, I am very
harsh against you and your character.
But notice before all of this, I did not
go after your family. I did not go after
your kids. I did not go after your wife.
I do not go after you as a person, as an
individual in the sense of you being a
creepy predator person. Okay? However,
however, the moment you take aart that
bar, it's just all out war and it's
nasty and it's bad for everyone. Okay?
>> But here's the thing, okay? You didn't
want to deescalate and now we're here.
Okay? Adult decisions, adult
consequences. All right? Yes. Push,
pull. You are in your 40s. You need to
figure this out. Okay? You're like twice
my age. Twice. You're twice my age, bro.
You're like 50% more of my age or some
[__] All right. No, you're you're
you're almost twice my age. There's no
excuse for any of this immaturity. Okay.
There there's just no excuse. All right.
You're It's crazy how immature you are.
Like I'm actually flabbergasted. I'm
like,
>> I don't know. Like I I think this is
crazy to me. Okay. Like
>> would you always say would you always
say dad's behaving
>> prepubescent for a job?
you let a trans girl get more like
mature than you or some [__] like that.
But that's crazy. Okay, Doc, you need to
go through puberty again. I'm just
saying. [laughter] Maybe your balls
haven't dropped.
>> I'm just saying.
>> Just drink a martini. Shaken, not
stirred.
>> Sand man.
>> Yo, thank you so much, Meu. Thank you so
much for the five Australian. Thank you.
Um, but yeah, uh, there you go. That's
the stupid [__] And I um and I'm just
going to assume I'm just going to assume
that like um J Stalk is gonna
is going to make a [__] segment on me
later because of Dan. Okay. So, I mean,
good job engaging in anti-fan tactics, I
guess. Like, good for you. I'm glad that
you can learn something out of this
entire drama. And that something is not
from Destiny, but it came from JTOK
instead. I'm glad you really learned
something. Okay. I'm glad that
everyone's loy so loyal.
>> So Dan has just uh messaged me saying,
"I didn't care at first, but now that
food shops is calling me a child, I
think I'm seriously at risk."
So that's
a self-defense situation, I fear. Okay,
we've got
I want to see a bit of the JTalk
segments that fill in the gap
between these next two streams. So,
we've seen most of this Dan enters
Discord. Do we want maybe
Jook's commentary on the Dan entering
his Discord?
>> Undisclosed Ethereum payments.
>> Guy used to mine a lot of crypto. Okay,
you'll never be able to find the money,
but he did pay me. I'm I'm not going to
not cap. Okay, five figures
>> server anti-fan communities in order to
complain about me. Okay,
so we have the friend of destiny
fratronizing with the enemy. Okay,
>> if you're in, let's say you're watching
this, maybe you're watching food shops,
watch this.
>> If you if you found that that statement
right there compelling, a loser, you
will never do anything tangible in the
world. Please yourself and give back
some of that oxygen and ozone you taken
up. Okay, thank you.
>> So that's what's happening. Okay. Do you
think Dan is on the other side? I think
that somehow because he's so spiteful
that he has decided it would be a great
idea.
>> Yeah, we got to see Jay use some of my
cont.
Okay. Yes, it's as crazy as it sounds.
>> You know, I love watching people watch
me.
>> This person named Hassan, but make no
mistake, this is Dan. I I believe that.
>> Wait, replay it. Oh, she said something
about fratinizing.
>> So, that's what's happening. And even
though he never talks there, he went on
to J Steel server anti-fan communities
in order to complain about me. Okay,
so we have the friend of destiny.
>> Oh, right here. Yeah, let's
>> patronizing with the enemy. Okay.
>> Isizing with the enemy. The enemy.
Cool. Uh, so yeah, if you find that
compelling, you are a loser. There's no
enemies here. Um, any of you people are
welcome to come and argue about where I
was wrong with any of my coverage of the
Destiny stuff. Boot Trap's too scared to
do it. You're all too scared to do it.
So you sit in your community probably
off the law together being total
degenerates. I really can't think of any
better hell. I can't do anything worse
to you than you've already done to
yourselves. Okay.
>> So that's what's happening. Okay. Do you
think Dan is on the other side? I think
that somehow because he's so spiteful
that he has decided it would be a great
idea to um complain about me on Jason.
>> This is the one thing me and Destiny is
unique in his community. Okay. He's good
with he likes but most of the other
people around him and me we can all come
together against you in Destiny in our
disgust at okay we are we are disgusted
by you guys we will always just you know
I will make content out of you I will
make a mockery of you for being a
whenever I want whenever I can okay and
Dan will enjoy it Dan will take part in
it Dan might join and talk about you
probably not to be honest but
>> we all hate we all do and you are one
okay Yes, it's as crazy as it sounds.
Okay, so this person named Hassan, but
make no mistake, this is Dan. I I
believe that multiple people have told
me that this is Dan. Yes, it is Dan, the
person with the so-called Hassan
account. Okay,
>> so um you'll notice that the tag, the
server tag right here is redact or
redact.dev. Okay, obviously the real
Hassan would never have anything.
>> Oh, this person's very serious.
So, right. Um, so I'm being told,
>> I mean, wouldn't it be crazier if the
real Hassan was in my Discord dropping
food shops tweets?
>> Wouldn't that be way more crazy than
Dan? This being Dan. Guys, this isn't
the real I know you think this is the
real Hassan, but it's actually just Dan
Saltman. No, it would be way more insane
if
anti right now.
>> Yeah, I don't know how much this I care
about.
>> You said that feeling
>> leaked DM. Oh, there's this stuff.
>> I didn't know this, but apparently.
Okay.
>> Oh, no. I We could go over that one,
too. I'll give that a second. Okay, we
do have that clip.
>> Talking to a 17-year-old. No. How do you
stand to watch so many commentators when
all the make fun of degenerate gooners?
They're targeting you. To be fair, they
are gooners, too. Lyrics. True. Larry is
a gooner. Well, yeah. Chud talks about
gawk every 5 seconds. Lol. I can't
believe this cute IRL lolly Japanese
girl is in in this space who is actually
into me. This is why I think I'm being
catfished. The chances can't be
possible. Well, let's see. No evidence
of your identity or existence, but
that's okay. I guess the pictures can be
AI generated. Hm. So, I don't know
anything about this person other than
I've been told this person.
>> No, I think we'll watch this. I think
this be funny.
>> What's up? Who is this?
>> Okay. They to be clear. So, food shops
doesn't get you in a little a little
gotcha. They told food shops. I don't
think this person
>> Yeah, I don't think this person has
advertised that they're overage or
sorry, underage.
>> Yeah, they told food shops they were 18.
I think the biggest issue here is that
when food shops figured out that they
were lying about their age, they didn't
ban them. Uh I believe the screenshots
in or are in order, but that at one
point they're asking food shops like why
why am I like banned from your server
and they're like oh you're 17. So they
figured out they were a minor and then
kept you know correspondence with them
and all that. Yeah. did not message this
person
>> thinking that they were 17. However,
this is like insanely reckless because
they were sent one picture of this
person's wait.
>> God,
>> can I just ask what you think cute IRL
lolly Japanese girl means?
>> Um, so food shops, I believe, God, it's
been months since I covered this. Food
shops, I think, said that this person
would send them like audio clips or
something. I don't know. They did like
lolli roleplay. They did like lolly
roleplay with each other where they
would and pretend to be like lollies and
underage and [__]
>> Cool.
>> Hi. I would like to point out something
just, you know, to be fair, to be
transparent. Hi, Mal. Um,
>> hi.
>> Mal has a crush on food shops.
>> I have a crush on the idealized version
of food shops. I don't think
>> What are we doing here?
>> So, no, no, you're now you're
misremembering things. I think food
shopping has the potential.
>> She can be hot.
>> She could be hot.
>> Yeah. You're looking
>> She has the potential to get there, but
she's not there yet.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I think she's far too lazy to ever get
there, so I don't think it would ever
work out.
>> Okay. But you know, there there's a
twinge there's a twinge somewhere in
your body.
>> Uh I think it's I think they're fairly
repulsive right now. It's like um you
know when you see like a homeless like
homeless like Down syndrome girl in New
York and you're like [laughter]
>> how are you like still talking normal
something normal just got said you have
a you have like a gun right next to you
don't you? [laughter]
>> Uh where is it? Oh no I moved it. I
moved it cuz I was sitting on my ear.
>> Do you hear that? Can my mic pick that
up?
>> Sorry. You continue. I didn't I just I
had a intrusive thought. Go ahead.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Yeah. I think I think there are
pictures of food shops where they like
brush their hair, they, you know, take
nice pictures, they try to look nice,
but um I I don't think that's often. And
I think if they really tried, they could
look attractive, but their hair's like
greasy, they don't shower, they don't
brush their hair, they don't brush their
teeth, they don't try to look good.
There's like a clip of them on stream
where they're actively like with their
their contacts, and it's just very
repulsive behavior. But I think um I
think they have the potential, you know?
I think they it's a missed opportunity
more or less. Where were you going with
the homeless Down Syndrome
situation?
>> Oh, yeah. I Okay, back to that. If
you're in like New York and you see like
a homeless Down Syndrome girl like on in
in Times Square or something, you're
probably not going to look.
>> Dude, I saw her crazy clip earlier.
I don't know if I can see it.
Yeah, this is just how I mute and reply.
[laughter] I don't even say it.
at that and be like, "Oh, I'd want to
hit that." But you'd probably look at
that and be like, "Oh, that's a missed
opportunity." Like, she's in the big
apple. She has, you know, every
opportunity in front of her. She she the
sky's the limit. She could look good.
She could look beautiful. She could look
amazing, but she's not. You know, she's
homeless in Times Square like with a
foam cup that she's begging for money
with. It's It's missed opportunity.
>> Like in the same way that like like
could be hot to you. the homeless person
in New York could be hot to me. I think
like like I said,
>> Down syndrome.
>> Down syndrome specifically.
>> Down syndrome was more so a a
metaphorical,
you know, term to express how disgenic
and freakish this homeless girl looked.
I don't think it would actually be Down
syndrome. It's more so to convey how bad
they look in this, you know, instance of
them being homeless.
>> Okay. So, not mentally.
>> It's also, you know, like when you see
like a fat guy, I'm sure you see this,
right? Do you ever go to the gym? You go
to the climbing gym, right?
Not these days, but I've
>> Do you ever go to the gym or go out for
walks or something and you see like a
fat loser and you kind of look at it and
you're like, you know, maybe if he if
he, you know, exercised and, you know,
put a little effort into his outfits and
into his swag and maybe, you know, got a
haircut, combed his hair a certain way,
he'd probably
>> Great stuff, man. Really
>> hell on your part. So, no, my my point
here is not also I think food shops is
like
>> like the bare minimum you can do. No,
no, no. Actually, I take that all back.
Sorry, I need to just get this thought
out. No, not knowing not knowing that
you can't put those quotes on the
internet. Not knowing that those are
like like totally that is the terrifying
thing. Putting all of her statements
about like children on the internet.
>> So, not knowing how socially degenerate
that is. That's that is the problem.
>> So, am I just not allowed to be like
racist on stream anymore?
>> Why? What does that come from?
>> Food shop said something about Loi and
now they can't age play in DMs. Am I Am
I just not allowed to like make racist
jokes about black women on stream
anymore? Like is that the standard we're
using?
>> You're in You're in the States, aren't
you? She's just allowed to be racist.
>> Um I don't think
>> so. I think Chops is allowed to lolly
role play with consenting adults.
>> Yeah, being racist.
>> I'm telling you that all of it ending up
in public is the issue, right?
>> The fact that she
Oh, that they willingly made it public.
>> Yeah. And they're not joking.
>> I think we get the idea here.
>> I think I'm good in that. So then
there's
>> like for example, I wouldn't even walk
on the same
>> like not feeling it.
>> I want a cute little girl that I can
wrap my arms around.
>> So you like being
>> J goes over some history.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Like a partner.
>> Cool. Now on its own not damning. Okay.
on its own. Not damning. Weird given
some of the other things, right? Cuz
that makes it physical. That makes it
real. It makes it in the real world. But
hold on.
>> I'm only into the most feminine of the
most feminine.
>> That's what I'm
>> What does that mean? I need to I need to
have a little girl to wrap myself
around.
>> Oh, like you're like big spoon is what
you're saying.
>> Oh, I get [__]
>> I need to have like a 12-year-old. Just
in case you actually thought for a
second, oh, this is just like big little
stuff. That's totally normal.
>> What?
>> No,
>> no.
>> No, no, no, no.
Oh, boy. All right, that's
>> J is so entertaining sometimes. I
forget.
>> Wouldn't want to call him a Okay, that
would be really If you guys called this
person [laughter] for some reason after
these comments, that would be
inappropriate. Oh, we we've still got
some more food shop stuff. We got some
more content.
Let's see here. Probably got to watch
this clip from the therapy thing, the
exposure therapy. The old queen
>> errands that would be associated with
kids because I would be like I would
avoid errands that would be associated
with kids because I would be like, "Oh
my god, I don't want to even like
associate with it because it would give
me so much anxiety and it would send me
into like a panic attack or not a panic
attack but an anxiety attack, right?"
Um, so
>> so food chops basically expresses some
attraction to kids, gets totally mobbed
for it.
>> Wait, dude,
was this the trans person that stood up
at at your party and called the Muslims
transphobic. Trans council candidate
suspended by Scottish Greens over sexual
misconduct allegation. Allegations
against Brownie included include
allegedly sending inappropriate messages
to underage girls. H
Browning tried to kiss her at school
without permission when she was 15.
What's that? 13 rather just 13.
Not good. Not good.
Tries to pivot into saying I went to
therapy. I have PCD. This thing that
like it's OCD or something. It's you
have compulsive thoughts about images of
kids, but you don't have like the
long-term persistent attraction to kids.
So, she tries to come up with this
excuse when she realizes how bad it
sounds. Then eventually she pivots into
a different one. She
>> No, no, no. The victim was 13. The
victim was 13. Apparently Brown, the
trans person was older. So inappropriate
messages with a 13year-old when she was
16 and something with a 13year-old in
nondescript age,
but older than 13.
>> Holy [__]
>> Whoops, wrong one.
>> She pivots into I think she just stops
discussing it entirely after this,
right? She basically says, "Don't call
me a I'm not anything like that." But
she's put all the content online where
she's talked about wanting to have a
12-year-old wrapped around her. Where
she's talked about this whole thing
where she's going to explain that she
avoided errands apparently that would be
around kids. She's done a whole bunch of
stuff to try to deal with this POC,
quote unquote.
Seems like Queen's analysis, we might
maybe we could go back at some point.
Should we go back now? Seems like
Queman's analysis is something along the
lines of well it she's it seems like she
looked up PC
tried to take those criteria and then
tried to create a hypothetical that
perfectly exemplifies those criteria.
That makes no sense. I might I think I
should go back I think I should go back
and listen to what this hypothetical is
stigmatized because we don't want to
encourage that attraction. We don't want
to say that that attraction is okay. We
want to say no we prefer that people are
not attracted to kids. So that is the
stigmatization and it's a person they
want to stigmatize like you said because
they didn't choose that attraction and
we'll speed this up. We'll speed this
attraction that person should be
dstigmatized.
>> You know you know what's the funniest
thing but also like really ironic. I
think it's just the amount of exposure
therapy that I went through is what
[__] me over. Um because I
>> she was now calling her exposure
therapy.
>> Was that Kenny? I just heard Kenny
laugh. That was Kenny's laugh.
>> What you mean?
>> I think that's about I think that's what
she's going to say. I think that's what
she's going to say. have POCD, but I
went through um I guess self treatment
for POCD to the point
>> Oh, never mind.
[laughter]
>> So, this is her self treatment for PCD
is off to
Okay, sorry. Drawing depictions of kids
in situations, hardcore situations.
Okay, that was her self-prescribed
treatment for these thoughts she was
having about minors.
>> Ship.
>> Yeah, I I guess Oh, she's actually out
of her mind. She needs to stop talking
about this immediately. me the [__] out
of here, dude. It's insane. Went through
self treatment.
>> Kenny Kenny is literally like, "No,
you're my favorite. Stop talking about
this. I don't want you to be outed,
Kenny. Kenny, your being outed, bro. No
to the point where I became so unicked
when it came to this subject that like
now I talk about it so unfiltered to the
point where I became so on the phone
cognizant to
that
>> like
I just like no longer become cognizant
to how other people react to it and then
like that [__] me over. Um,
>> dude, this person literally does not
under like they actually just say things
with no attachment to like they're not
driving at a meeting at a meeting.
They're just like saying words over and
over and over again.
Like she's trying to say I'm I you know
I this became so normalized for me that
I talk about it and it weirds people out
and I have no idea. But she's just like
she keeps doing the word salad over and
over again.
>> Yeah, if that makes sense. I don't know
if that makes sense.
>> Okay.
>> I'm really question about the self
treatment exposure because it sounds a
little we're getting into some territory
where I'm like, "Wait a minute. What are
you talking about?"
>> We can we can get into that. We can get
into that. I'm right here. Yeah. Don't
worry.
>> She's agreeing.
>> So, so meanwhile, um can I So, you had
doubts about um you had doubts on um
>> Yes, that is what she's saying. Frugals.
Yes, she is saying she watched so much.
She dropped off so much to try to get
rid of these thoughts she had about
children that she forgot that children
was weird to other people and then she
started talking about it in public on
her stream. That is that is her those
are her words precisely. So when Dan
calls her a and she calls him a in
return, I would ask does Dan have any
similar clips on the internet? Does Dan
have anything like this on the internet
where he talks so much he thinks it's so
normal to say kids he just talks about
it repeatedly? Is there anything like
this for Dan? Because when Dan says it,
I see a basis. I see some merit to the
claim. When food shop says it, it seems
like it's just a child getting mad that
they're being outed for stuff they have
said on the internet and it's been
recorded
>> of what I went through. Right. So, I'm
going to send you some things. All
right. Um, so
>> the doubts were because of the way you
verbally described them the first two
times I heard it when in your first
conversation with Resi, your first one
conversation with him from a couple
months ago
when he was covering the math panel and
those two descriptions did not match up
with what I understood about uh
>> actual just gem content. So when we went
over on stream and went international
OCD Foundation's uh article on it and
went through all the details and it
still didn't line up with even what that
was describing.
>> Sure. I can I can explain. Yeah. So, but
first of all, before we get through
that, um this is the uh uh I just sent
you a picture. This is um this is the um
surgery that I take. The little actual
pill bottle that I take. Um so, I'm
going to pull this
>> is prescribed for a number of different
illnesses.
>> It's up for chat.
>> Yeah. [clears throat] You can you can
see the cat on there. Um that's me. Um
and uh this is I know that you don't
doubt. Oh, also just to be clear when we
say you like are in a community, by the
way, if you're watching this, if you've
come from food shops community, we say
you're in a community, this is what
we're referring to. You are in a literal
community. You until proven otherwise,
we consider all of you. Okay. Okay. You
you will have to gain back normal human
being status over time in any other
community. Okay? You come back here from
that community, you're a until proven
otherwise. Okay? Not sure how that
happens, but listen, we'll figure it
out. me, but I know there's a lot of
people out there in the audience that
doubt me.
Um, yeah. Here you go, guys. Uh, this
is, uh, this is a searching. I'm just
letting you guys know that. Wow.
>> I know that people doubt me. So, there
you go,
>> bro. Bro, we'll see the graphs. We got
to see the graphs.
>> Let's go.
>> I haven't
ch
>> uh No, I haven't seen guys. If you watch
my video for the chart.
>> For the chart, guys. Where is it?
>> Got a chart she's going to show us. All
right,
>> guys. I need to pull this up. I need to
show you guys what she's referring to.
If you were here earlier, you saw it.
You saying video. There's the chart.
[laughter]
>> This person's brain is totally fried.
Like, this person's brain no work no
more. Okay. Holy [__] Are you serious?
Dude, there's no way. Why? Again, all
she had to do was ignore Dan calling her
a and none of this stuff gets gone over
by all of these people again, right? She
just had to avoid it. Just ignore it.
Just ignore it. Don't look it up. But
instead, she does this. Incredible.
Amazing.
>> Oh, is that the chuck?
Wait, I missed the whole see this
>> OCD PDF P OCD anxiety on
babe but but but anxiety on something
cons imply consume
consume PDF consume
I okay I fantastic stuff okay
>> no fantastic
>> we are in exceptions this is lazy
content the wall and still have PCD
>> yeah man it's a shame Like that would be
I just use that as a thumbnail, but no
one would watch it. But me, that's
amazing.
>> Oh, man. I watched it earlier. It's just
brilliant, dude. Holy [__]
>> Wow.
>> Um, all right. Can I Can I draw up this
for you?
>> Sure.
>> Just doing it again, guys. We're getting
a redux. We're getting a ret.
>> Okay. Um, so, uh, we have
>> Listen, the chart before it was a little
confusing. We have to draw the chart
again. It'll make more sense why food
shops thought she was a
>> Wow, this is actually 2 years almost to
the day since this video came out. 30th
of November 2023. That's crazy.
>> PCD, but she still off to Lollcon. And
because she still off to Lollcon, it
doesn't mean she has thoughts about
actual kids. Okay, now this will all
make sense as soon as she can finish the
chart. And don't forget, guys, this is a
Connor approved segment. All right, we
have the Connor Valor Media seal of
approval that's going to go up here.
>> Okay, so we have OCD. Oh, sorry. Can you
see this? Let's give it a look.
>> Um, hopefully you
>> I can see. Yeah,
>> [__] I wish I had my pen with me. So,
[laughter]
hopefully hopefully So, this is going to
be a little bit complicated, but
hopefully you can sort of wrap your mind
around this. So, um, uh, just because,
you know, mental health is sort of a
little OCD. All right. So, this is OCD.
Um, and then on the other side we have
actual. Okay.
>> So, this is cinema. This you're watching
cinema.
>> This is so these are two completely
different things. So, OCD um, is an
umbrella. All right. And OCD,
>> this is a little bit better. This is a
little better. This is just two section
an
um anx
thing where it can have many.
So, one of these manifestations can be
is classic manifest. So, um this can be
PCD. And what is PCD? It is specifically
the anxiety of um anxiety of oh my god,
I'm so afraid that I am a or I'm afraid.
>> [__] it's already gone. We started so
good with the two sessions. It's already
we're already just drawing lines
everywhere.
>> Some act but you are not actually
>> I remember listening to this waiting for
a coke dealer to arrive. So do you
follow?
>> Awesome.
>> Okay. So um since you are that way so
now let's bring in another part of the
equation. Lollycon I mean
>> wait wait wait wait wait
no way.
Why did dev just say I knew a person who
escalated?
Wait what?
>> Okay
>> what? What if exposure therapies to make
you not overly anxious around children?
Not children. Yes.
And Dev says, "I knew a person who
escalated."
>> Does he mean from like volleycon to or
wait, what is he? Okay. No, I I don't
even want. Okay.
>> I don't even want to guess.
>> So, we have now let's just say that um
you
>> are. So, so
>> this is just pure, right? Well, yes. And
yes. So, yes, as in it's definitely Yes.
As in it's definitely cope. Why are you
drawing something that doesn't need to
be drawn? You could just explain this.
You don't need to draw this. These these
aren't even like things that are like
literally all she had to do is say I
have PCOD P OCD consuming doesn't make
me a and then explain why
OCD anxiety PCD
anxious about being a like none of this
is the chart is not helping right now.
It's not helping communicate any
concept. So let's just put the easy part
of the equation out of the way. Okay. So
if you're and you consume okay it's
pretty obvious why might consume right
is because um you know childlike right
so since it's
>> interesting choice of words not draw
child
>> I like um that's why consume. Does this
make sense so far?
>> Yeah it would be someone who is
attracted to the aspect that they are a
child with usually features. Okay.
>> Okay. I'm I'm going to make a prediction
here. All this diagram is going to say
is it's going to
>> she's okay. Hold on. I'm going to make a
prediction about Quinn's going to make a
prediction about this diagram is just
going to like basically lay out the fact
that she is being called a or that she
has PCD and it's going to say this is
it's okay for PCD people with PCD to
>> food shops used to say that she did like
some computer science [__] I know like
software dev or something and made
destiny money that was her exact quote
used to make destiny money
so embarrassing brolly
because they don't have the primary
attraction. There will be no reckoning
with like any of the points or anybody's
like questions. It'll just say no. PCD
means not PCD means not. I have given I
have given myself PCD. That means not
going to be her saying no. I could be a
but actually it's just cuz I've got PCD.
That's all she's going to say with this
diagram. That's why that's that's my
right now.
>> Now here now here is a trick question.
Ready? Here's a trick question. Now here
is a normal person.
>> Here's a normal person who does not have
OCD. Does not have
Why might be consume?
>> If they're seeking it out specifically,
it would be one of a number of of
things. It would
>> be they don't have defined in the BSM,
but they still have a attraction to
children in some capacity. Right. could
either be um as you mentioned the power
dynamic between the adult and the child
that extreme power dynamic or it could
also be the more um the more childlike
behavior which can also be sought out in
adult related like uh infantilization
ventilization and uh and then it could
also
>> Okay guys, I've got a message from Smith
the Five Nights at Freddy's enthusiast
was on earlier. Before you make me
famous with your stream, just know I'm a
in a fantasy I would be with Toy Chica
but in reality I wouldn't because it
would be weird. [laughter]
>> Just just a note there. be like,
>> "Yeah, you also mentioned that you might
not like, oh, I got like, oh, I got
caught um I got caught, you know, with
my promotions. My boss, my my boss,
boss, boss, boss, boss, you know,
promotions, right?" Like, like getting
hot porn is very popular also because um
it's just very popular, right? So So
again,
>> not leave my ass alone because a normal
person into this could be a reason why
somebody with OCD might also be into
lolly, right?
>> So she's saying one reason she could be
a normal person could be into is because
it is like a guilty thing. They could
feel guilt what
porn is very popular also because of
guilt. Um yeah, it's just very very
popular, right? So, so again, this is
>> is this true? I don't even know. I don't
even know if the things she's saying
here are true. I'm already I've already
got questions.
>> A reason why normal person.
>> Wow. Okay, I think we've seen enough of
this. We can move on to the next part
now.
We get the vibe. I think we got the
vibe. Anything else we care about here?
All right.
So, this is a crash after
by the way. Okay. Because people have in
fact and I won't try to explain this. So
food shops has actually never been
diagnosed with PCD. I don't know why
she's insisting this
as I understand she's never been
diagnosed PD PC
>> much because uh stress effect is a real
thing. Like the straws effect is a real
thing. So I'll just explain once. Okay.
the the straw the straw
>> PC meme comes from the fact that at some
point
>> I mean because of my like because like
part of um whenever I need to like feel
horny and jerk off or whatever the [__]
I look at like [__]
>> I look at you know what right but
obviously back then I felt guilty about
looking at it and because I have OCD and
this is like really embarrassing the
guilt from looking at something like
that is the POCD. What the therapist
helped me to do is reach
>> PCD is no better than being a pedo. I
mean, they're both mental illnesses, but
POCD
in theory doesn't make people offend, I
think. Right.
It's not actually an attraction to
children. You You have a form of OCD
that causes you like compulsive
anxiety attacks.
over the thought that you might be a
pedophile, over the thought that you
might be attracted to children.
Thank you for the membership. Thank you
of acceptance where I shouldn't hate
myself. I shouldn't feel guilt
towards that because guilt leads to more
destructive behaviors. So the therapist
just simply said, "Yeah, you know what?
I think I would rather have you improve
and be happy and do what you want
with no direct harm towards anybody IRL,
then be guilty, feel guilty, and feel
bad about yourself." And I completed the
therapy. I paid $200 per hour. Okay,
$200 per hour.
for
an amazing OCD therapist. Okay. Top of
the line. All right.
Oh, hi Emory. Looping. You mean
explaining just once where I explain the
straws the [__] straw sand effect?
Stryand is it is it stand? It's stand
where I explained the stryand effect.
But okay. $200 a dollar ain't no way. I
paid out of pocket. Okay. By the way,
Emry,
I noticed that you haven't um you
haven't uh Minecrafted yet. Okay.
I remember that Mr. Girl call where you
called in and you said you were feeling
Robloxy. Okay. Hope you're doing well.
>> Wow.
>> Do it faster. Anyway, [clears throat]
but yeah. Um just in case you guys do
not know about the thing because guess
what? I have an entirely new audience
now. But the new audience is still
getting exposed to the PCD talking point
thing. All right. So whenever they see,
for example, I beef with anti-fans a lot
and anti-fans are going to bring up, oh
yeah, the therapist prescribed me lolly
kind of [__] right? That's a very
disingenuous way of putting um oh yeah,
improvement in order in a way where I no
longer hate myself. I no longer feel
guilt over consuming any of that. and
developing emotional regulation and not
spiraling out of control. I'm just
saying. I'm just saying like I'm way
better now
than I was before.
>> Yeah, I think PCD especially is one of
those things you probably shouldn't talk
about online if you suffer with it
unless you're like, you know, super
confident in your ability to articulate
the issues and where you're at with it
and you're like super confident in your
diagnosis and treatment.
you know,
it's it's it's like out of it. Thank you
for the membership, Joseph. Thank you.
Huge appreciated. Um,
like almost any mental illness, it's
like one of those that is just like most
prone for being
misunderstood or, you know, setting off
alarm bells.
Probably just deal with it. Pro deal
with it offline.
Unless you're like a, you know, going
full-blown like advocate.
>> So, uh, yeah. You know what? I don't
>> But I don't believe this person has PS
anyway.
>> Okay. If you want to say prescribe
lolly, that's fine. Okay. I'm just
saying.
>> Anyway.
>> Okay.
[clears throat]
So,
did he run away when he realized he was
[__]
and incredibly confident about something
he had no idea about? Blah blah blah.
H.
So, Puddles was definitely screenshot
sent to preach. I mean, does it matter?
Isn't it like a public server? Wait,
hold on.
I'm being told
that Emory most likely have not
graduated high school and
[__] their own cousin.
What is wrong with you people?
Just rumors. Okay. Anyway,
>> powerful.
>> I hope they tell food slops. I hope the
feds get them. So,
>> this is basically it. Okay.
>> Wow, guys. So, so I think that's the
food shops versus Dan drama
pretty much. I think that's pretty much
it.